[Music]
[Applause]
I needed some professional help well
I've been told that before professional
help on what happened with Tua in that
situation once again talking to a former
NFL quarterback who said if I was at a
party and I got up and stumbled like
that twice would you let me drive home
the answer is no if I was a boxer and I
stumbled twice in the ring and had to be
helped up would you let me continue to
fight and the answer is no so Tua the
dolphin sent us a note saying this
morning he did not have a concussion
it's back and ankle injury but it feels
like
uh you know that this was in the Bills
game and now the game against the
Bengals so that's that's the first
concussion apparently that he's had but
the independent neurologist got fired
what did he do wrong that's what I want
to know because eventually it's the team
Doctor Who says I'm going to sign off
and send him back in is he disciplined
and what'd they do wrong
Tom pellicero he's supposed to have
answers to this the NFL reporter joins
us now so walk me through this so I can
understand how we got to this point Tom
uh to to complicate a question Dan
because let's start with that game on
last Sunday a week ago uh against the
bills we all saw the same thing on TV
which is the two gets up shakes his head
takes a few steps kind of loses his
balance takes a couple more steps than
his teammates kind of grab him I think
that everyone watching is saying that's
somebody who has a concussion he goes in
the locker room and he goes in the
second quarter gets checked out comes
out in the third quarter and the word
comes quickly from the dolphins that it
was in fact a back injury and not a head
injury that had suffered which is how he
ends up getting clear and obviously four
days later he's being checked every day
they're required under the protocols to
check him the day after the game because
he had a concussion check they
voluntarily do it just to monitor just
to make sure each day leading up to the
Thursday night game and then he suffers
one of the most horrific looking
concussions that we've seen uh in the
modern NFL so while that's going on the
NFL PA which initiated an investigation
which they're allowed to do Under the
CBA right after uh the Sunday incident
is beginning its investigation the day
after the Cincinnati game they interview
both the unaffiliated neurotrauma
consultant and the Dolphins team
physician who had been in on the
concussion check by Saturday they had
informed the UNC uh that they were
terminating him my understanding of why
the unaffiliated neurologist was
terminated was a combination of he did
not understand his role as the UNC did
not understand what he was supposed to
be doing even though again this is an
individual who under the CBA has to be a
highly qualified surgeon or
neurospecialist they're approved by the
NFL and NFL PA until they're not but did
not seem to understand that he did not
work for the league that he was there on
behalf of the welfare of players and
then also that he became hostile uh in
the interview process which led the
union to believe that he did not have
players best interests at heart and
therefore they exercised their right to
terminate it now I would also tell you
from what I understand the league was
not happy that they terminated him and
that word got out quickly after they
informed the player reps that they had
taken that step which then leads you to
to the statement we had on Saturday
night joined from the NFL and nflpa
saying they have agreed to address the
gross motor instability which is in
essence the loophole that allowed them
to say it was his back not his head and
that gets him back onto the field my
understanding is they've already agreed
on the parameters they're working out
final language there's a process they
have to go through to finalize it but
that's going to be uh changed here but
that statement also said the
investigation is ongoing to this point
I'm paraphrasing here there's been no
wrongdoing found in other words and no
one at this point has ruled the two
actually had a concussion last Sunday
and what the Dolphins told you this
morning is the same thing that I've been
told by many people involved here which
is based on all the medical information
he didn't had to have a concussion that
still leaves open the question number
one how did the doctors come to the
conclusion the two is back not his head
caused the stumble and if the concussion
checklist as they call it was fully
checked and no problem calls were
violated then it becomes I think
relatively obvious that the public
appetite and the player's appetite for
what players should go back onto the
field that this fell below the block
but go back to what a former quarterback
told me over the weekend if you were at
a party and you saw somebody get up and
stumble and then stumble again would you
let that person Drive
well and that's precisely what they're
trying to eliminate now with these
updated protocols what the union wants
here and it's going to be some form of
this is eliminating the medical judgment
aspect of the gross motor instability in
other words if you stumble you are out
of the game and there's not somebody
deciding well it was because of this and
remember these are doctors you go to
your doctor you don't just say hey Doc
what's wrong with me like you probably
go hey my foot's hurting or my back's
hurting so the first thing they're doing
is asking tool what's going on if he's
saying it's my back then they're taking
that into consideration again it's up to
them to make the medical judgment what
this updated protocols will do now is
say there is no judgment You're simply
coming off the field but that also could
potentially have unintended consequences
which for what Dr Alan Sills the chief
NFL's chief medical officer told us
yesterday is part of the conversation
now I mean think about a situation where
Patrick Mahomes in the playoffs a couple
of years ago yeah got hit gets up he
stumbles he's got a knee injury his knee
buckles for a second get any wobbles and
gets back up well now is Patrick Mahomes
being pulled off the field in a playoff
game if in fact the language is that
clear the answer will be yes
pulling off players from the field even
if they don't have concussions okay but
when does this new language get inserted
here is this starting now the hope is it
will be for week five okay it will be in
effect for week five though by putting
out that statement on Saturday that was
intended if people weren't all ready to
put everyone on in the league on notice
that when in doubt get them out I think
there are about a dozen Players
yesterday who were announced as being
evaluated for concussions the only one
I'm aware of who went back into the game
uh was Justin Reed the chief safety
because like Brian Hoyer Tyrod Taylor
did not return to the game that's not
abnormal a lot of the players who
checked for concussions end up having
concussions and being held out of the
game but I think it's fair to say
everybody is on high alert right now
understanding um the scrutiny here and
justifiably so for exactly what happened
with Tua
yeah I still don't know why the doctor
if the did the independent neurologist
do his job
uh did the team doc the team doctors
send him back in as well I don't know if
anybody has a problem with that if he's
facing disciplinary action plus nobody's
really addressed a back injury that led
to it to have that reaction Tom that's
what I don't understand here that that
appeared to be pretty serious to me
well certainly and it's he was on the
injury report with back and Ankle
injuries uh during the course the week
we don't know the entirety of what
treatment was put into place there what
we do know is what Tua said which was
that he thought it happened on a
quarterback sneak earlier and then it
locked up again we know what our eyes
tell us there's also two medical doctors
who are supposed to be making these
decisions which I think that you know if
there's one other thing that comes out
of this I think it's from all the
coaches I've talked to with other teams
people who know Mike McDaniel people who
don't everyone to a man says this is
literally why the protocols exist is to
keep the coaches out of it so the coach
isn't making the Judgment so to the
extent that Mike McDaniel should
override the doctors on their medical
judgment that that's uh that's a hard
one coaches are are taught to leave the
medical evaluation to the doctors take
their information back if the player can
go in
um then he can go back in but you know
two again back to the point of what the
process is with the team position and
the unaffiliated neurotrauma consultant
under the collective bargaining
agreement the team physician exclusively
makes that decision the unaffiliated
neurotrauma consultant can ask questions
to the player they can offer information
and opinions it is a team physician who
makes the call on both does this player
have a concussion and can he return to
play Dr Alan Sills said he's not aware
of any situation that came down to a
coin flip and they educate everyone to
if there's two differing opinions to
take the more conservative opinion and
remove the player which tells you in
this case both doctors agreed that Tua
should be able to go back into the game
but it is ultimately the team
Physician's responsibility under the CBA
talking to Tom pellicero the NFL Network
Insider by the way Giants Packers live
on NFL Network Sunday at 9 30 a.m
Eastern from London is there any
protocol for afib with J.J watt getting
his heart shocked back into Rhythm here
that's that's something that we've seen
um usually there's a handful of players
through the combine process every year
who get flagged for regular heartbeats
um afib is not I mean I'm not in any way
it's of course it's not my heart so I'm
never going to call it a minor injury
just because I don't have it but it is
something that's relatively common and
they're able to do something with it you
know JJ Watt going and playing a game uh
three days later obviously again he and
the medical doctors made the decision
that that was going to be uh something
that was safe for him to do so it's not
completely unprecedented I would
certainly think that's something that
they're going to monitor going forward
but he went out and played like JJ Watt
and had a pretty big tip ball there late
in the game
we brought this up in the first hour you
know having a third string quarterback
on the sidelines without taking a roster
spot
can you have I mean is that a big deal I
know you get to add two practice players
so you're up to 55 but can you have like
a you know an extra goalie in hockey you
know just something in case so instead
saquon Barkley is going to be your third
string quarterback here well they had
that for years I think that went away I
don't know off the top of my head but I
want to say around 2008 or so that they
eliminated that really used to have the
third quarterback dress as the 46th man
and the change that they made to the
roster rules was now you just get 46.
what happened was a lot of teams started
keeping up an extra linebacker or DB or
something for special teams and so it's
really only in cases where a player
comes into a game with an injury right
now that you see the third quarterback
active on game day but we've seen I mean
several situations here and I certainly
think that with the updated concussion
protocol that has to factor into
people's thinking here which is that
there's a higher percentage chance that
a player could be taken off the field
even if they don't have a concussion uh
for a precaution you may see more teams
taking that under evaluation similar to
how for a long time a lot of teams only
carried two quarterbacks then covet hit
everybody started having a third
quarterback then covet also changed the
roster rules you could have veterans on
your practice squad you can Elevate
those players I would I would think
that's something that teams are going to
have to address here everybody's got
their you know their emergency
quarterback and then the emergency
emergency quarterback like I thought
that was one of the interesting parts of
the Patriots game yesterday was the
reporters who cover the team going well
Jacoby Myers is the emergency fourth
quarterback but he's inactive we don't
know who the fifth quarterback is but
you're one you're one play away from uh
from that coming into play at least
Bailey zappy went out and for a rookie
from Western Kentucky he checked it
around pretty good
um most importantly I'll save this for
last it's far more serious than the
other things uh DK Metcalf going to be
listed on the injury list for uh you
know being carted off with that whatever
tragic injury that he had in the game I
will say this for DK Metcalf and you
know this is always why I always
hesitate to tweet or retweet when I see
a guy on cart who didn't have an obvious
injury because there are different
places they've encouraged players in
recent years to not go to the bathroom
on the sideline not to just have the two
guys with towels and you're under the
Gatorade coolers relieving yourself it
is a hike in Ford Field because you got
to go around the field you got to go up
the tunnel and then it's like the second
area up there it's it's a tough place
when Nature Calls there's like one
little bathroom and I know this because
every game it's one of the big things
Dan that I'm I'm always conscientious of
when I'm doing pre-game hits on NFL
Network which is how far am I where is
it what's the situation I can tell you
it's a two-stall bathroom that's
accessible off the field if not you got
to go all the way up and into the locker
room so it's smart move by DK he got
himself back a little quicker that's
great reporting right there why doesn't
NFL Network do a a story on best and
worst bathroom situation and then talk
to players about what that's like to try
to get man this has got Sports Emmy
written all over I might as well hand it
to you here Tom
here's what I'm going to do Dan I'm
going to make a tick tock just for you I
know you're big on Tick Tock oh yeah I
will make it I will start filming the
bathrooms for the rest of the year and
we'll see if we can come to a conclusion
by the end of this yes and I would like
diagrams I would like to have
explanations here uh but you test me
it's like George Costanza in New York
City I can tell you the best restroom
that the media is allowed to use in
every stadium in the NFL top of my head
I like that Tom thanks for joining us as
always hey time there Tom pelliser he
works for the NFL Network he's an
Insider and his newest project
assignment is I got to find out about
the bathroom situation